just want to bring you an update on the
line that's um coming into western
regarding dominic cummings um
after he went into durham traveled more
than 200 miles from london to
durham with kofi 19 symptoms let's bring
in our political correspondence
rob powell rob we've had a statement
from downing streets yeah the first uh
on the record statement from number 10 a
number 10 spokesman issuing
a statement in the last um five minutes
or so
saying uh owing to his wife being
infected with suspected coronavirus and
the high likelihood
that he would himself become unwell it
was essential for dominic cummings to
ensure his young child could be properly
cared for
his sister and nieces had volunteered to
help so he went to a house near to but
separate from his extended family
in case their help was needed his sister
shopped for the family
and left everything outside at no stage
was he or his family spoken to by the
police
about this matter as is being reported
his actions were in line with
coronavirus guidelines
mr cummings believed believes he behaved
reasonably
and legally so claiming that he didn't
really have
con or what was not addressed in there
is the extent to which he had contact
with his parents that's not addressed in
there at all but
suggesting anyway that he was in a
completely separate property
and it was in fact his sisters and
nieces that were dropping off shopping
and caring for him and his family no uh
not addressed in there either
where his young child was actually cared
for whether
um that purse whether that child was in
the in the separate property with the
couple
or whether the child was being cared for
separately by mr cummings's
um parents uh saying though that they he
believes that is within the spirit
of the law i have to say that the
guidelines at the time the restrictions
were
that if you are showing covert 19
symptoms you are not to leave your main
primary residence so i think there will
still be questions looming after that
statement of why they felt it necessary
to travel some 260 miles from northeast
london
to durham in order to get this
assistance was there no assistance
available
in the area of london where he was
living was it not possible for family
members perhaps to come and assist and
drop off shopping
at his property in london rather than
traveling from what at the time
obviously
was a hot spot london to a rural area
like durham as well so a statement
putting their side of the story forward
but i think still
a lot more questions over why
mr cummings made this lengthy uh journey
when everybody else
in the country was being told that even
if they were in
a dire situation suffering with symptoms
they should stay in their own property